mesdames messieurs bonsoir décidément la
sphère de l'assassinât du petit grégory
villemin dans les vosges devient de plus
en plus mystérieuse et on peut se
demander ce soir si elle n'a pas fait
une nouvelle victime
bernard laroche qui passait au début de
l' enquête pour le suspect numéro 1
vient d'être lavés d'un premier soupçon
ce n'est pas lui qui a écrit les
fameuses lettres anonymes adressées aux
parents de règle de grégory son avocat
vient de révéler que le juge
d'instruction avait acquis cette
conviction au terme de nouvelles
analyses graphologiques bernard laroche
a été remis la semaine dernière en
liberté provisoire après trois mois de
prison préventive
il a toujours clamé son innocence reste
évidemment que le corbeau existe bien et
que le mystère ne fait que s'épaissir
gendarmes en s'entraîner parce que
j'avais une écriture qui ressemble à
celle du cambon sont les soupes
logements plus que c'était pas moi j'ai
à gaza sera qu'elle n'a pas pu trouver
c'était moi est oui
bernard laroche a toujours nier mais
mais des expertises graphologiques
l'avait désigné comme le corbeau mais
saches une belle-soeur l'avait accablé
en détruisant son alibi et puis voici
que muriel s'est rétracté et voici qu'un
second groupe d'experts graphologue
affirmé aujourd'hui au juge lambert que
ce n'est pas bernard laroche l'auteur de
ces différentes lettres anonymes qui
menaçait de mort le petit grégory en
toute logique par conséquent le juge
lambert devrait être amenée à prononcer
un non lieu en faveur de cet homme de 29
ans qui vient de passer trois mois en
prison et qui surtout a été regardée
comme un monstre
certes il faut se garder aujourd'hui de
mettre autant de précipitation à voir en
la roche une victime innocente qu'on en
a mis à le regarder comme un coupable
mais il n'ya plus aujourd'hui aucune
raison objective si tenté qu'il y en ait
plus de le soupçonner lui en particulier
maintenant bien sûr reste à découvrir le
coupable c'est à cette condition est à
elle seule que bernard laroche pourra
peut-être réellement
jouir de sa liberté retrouvée